[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
mitri sirin ihnen alle im guten abend
und willkommen katja stresow ist mit mir
im studio auch der sport ist stark von
der situation in der ukraine beeindruckt
genau die großen verbände die reagieren
jetzt schon amt liebe zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer auch heute wollen wir ihnen
einen überblick über die wichtigsten
ereignisse im zusammenhang mit dem
russland ukraine krieg geben zur
militärischen lage es gibt weiter
schwere kämpfe etwa um kharkiv im
nordosten aber die ukraine können den
russischen vormarsch immer wieder
aufhalten in belarus haben die
kriegsgegner erstmals verhandelt die
erwartungen daran sind allerdings nicht
allzu groß
währenddessen fliehen immer mehr
menschen etwa 500.000 sollen es
inzwischen seien die
wirtschaftssanktionen zeigen wirkung der
rubel stürzt ab die russische
zentralbank
verdoppelt die zinsen in deutschland
wieder ein zeichen der solidarität
250.000 menschen auf der straße aus dem
rosenmontags wird ein friedens montags
zug statt froh sind ein bunter protest
gegen putins krieg
wir zeigen ihnen jetzt welche
auswirkungen der krieg in und für
russland hat volker dutschek und markus
kübler beginnen ihren beitrag aber dort
wo sich russische streitkräfte und
ukrainer derzeit massive gefechte
liefern in der zweitgrößten stadt des
landes in kharkiv
keine atempause für die millionenstadt
leidet besonders unter russischen
angriffen 1,5 millionen menschen leben
nahe der grenze zu russland in flammen
steht in der nacht auch diese schule
hier sollen sich vor tagen noch menschen
verschanzt haben panzer brennen die
menschen trauen sich nicht mehr aus
die russischen truppen haben in den
letzten drei stunden tages beschossen
sie haben viele zivile häuser getroffen
wir haben viele unschuldige leute die
verletzt oder getötet wurden
das vielleicht wichtigste ziel aller
angriffe hier spezialteams der polizei
suchen nach russischen saboteure
wir haben ungefähr 100 einheiten im
einsatz
nach wie vor versucht russland von drei
seiten die ukraine unter druck zu setzen
der vormarsch geht schleppender voran
als erwartet sagt zumindest das
britische verteidigungsministerium
aber eines scheint sicher die sanktionen
gegen russland zeigen wirkung der rubel
brach am morgen um mehr als 20 prozent
ein die zentralbank verdoppelte den
leitzins auf 20 prozent und sankt
petersburg sind die geldautomaten dicht
umlagert viele wollen ihr erspartes
lieber zu hause haben
seit donnerstag geht das so jeder rennt
von einer bank zur anderen um geld
abzuheben der eine hat glück der andere
nicht auch der kreml räumt erstmals ein
dass die sanktionen schaden das sind
schwere sanktionen sie sind
problematisch aber russland hat das
notwendige potenzial für eine
kompensierung des schadens durch die
sanktionen
ukraine präsident selensky will jetzt
schnell den eu beitritt seines landes
unser ziel ist es mit allen europäern
zusammen zu sein und was am wichtigsten
ist gleichberechtigt zu sein ich bin
sicher dass das fair ist ich bin sicher
dass wir es verdienen
es wird doch verhandelt nach vielen
verzögerungen die ukraine kommen mit dem
hubschrauber zum treffen nach gomel kurz
hinter der grenze in belarus zum ersten
mal im krieg ukrainer und russen an
einem tisch gedämpfter optimismus die
positionen weit auseinander
am ende ein teilerfolg beide seiten
verständigen sich auf ein zweites
treffen der genaue termin wird nicht
genannt
für uns in der west ukraine ist armin
coerper armin sie sind heute über polen
in die ukraine gereist was haben sie
erlebt
lemberg die stadt in der welt angekommen
sind lemberg ist eine stadt im krieg das
haben wir auf den ersten blick gesehen
als wir hier heute nachmittag
reingekommen sind nicht etwa weil hier
sehr ähneln heulen sondern weil man so
gut wie keine menschen auf der straße
gesehen hat was man sah man autos und
zwar sehr viele autos riesige staus rein
in die stadt und raus aus der stadt die
menschen die reinkommen das sind in der
regel binnen flüchtlinge die auf dem weg
nach westen in sicherheit sind raus aus
der stadt fahren leute die ihre ihre
angehörigen frauen und kinder oder
ältere menschen in sicherheit bringen
wollen lembeck hat sich auch zu einem
zentrum der hilfslieferungen entwickelt
hier wird blut gespendet
molotow-cocktails gebastelt und was auch
immer
was uns aufgefallen ist als wir hier
rein gefahren sind in die stadt aus
polen kommend wir kamen relativ gut
durch es gab checkpoints die haben uns
aber ziemlich in ruhe gelassen es waren
halt starke staus immer wieder aber das
ging eigentlich ziemlich
ungestört konnten wir hier rein fahren
an der grenze zwischen polen und der
ukraine fiel uns auf dass innerhalb des
grenzübergangs also quasi im
niemandsland sehr viele muslimische
aussehende männer sich aufhielt nicht
würde sagen mehrere hundert die
offensichtlich von den polnischen
behörden repariert wurden ich kann nicht
sagen dass gab ja meldungen in den
letzten tagen dass es sich dabei um
studenten aus der ukraine handelt die
versuchen zu flüchten oder was auch sein
kann dass ich da schon eine neue
flüchtlingswelle aus dem nahen osten
eine neue flüchtlingsräte durch das
kriegsland ukraine bildet danke für die
schilderung nach lemberg armin wir gehen
jetzt direkt weiter nach moskau dort ist
mein kollege christian selben christian
was bekommen sie denn mit von den
auswirkungen der sanktionen und dem
widerstand gegen diesen krieg in
russland
ich würde sagen die stimmung hier in
moskau die wird spürbar unruhiger werden
es den beitrag gerade gesehen es gibt
teilweise lange schlangen an den
geldautomaten das ist nicht
flächendeckend das ist nicht überall
aber die menschen versuchen noch bargeld
zu kriegen das klappt dann auch nicht
überall an manchen automaten gibt es gar
nichts mehr an anderen dann nicht so
viel wie sonst und ich glaube so langsam
sieg bei den menschen hier durch das
eine unruhige zukunft auf sie hier
wartet die im alltag viele entbehrungen
haben wird geht es dann auch um das
thema reisen wie kann man russland
überhaupt noch verlassen wenn es fast
gar keine flugverbindungen mehr gibt
also das kommt so langsam hier bei den
menschen an dann gab es heute noch einen
brief von oligarchen die ja sehr wichtig
sind im russischen machtgefüge und die
haben putin ganz offen kritisiert für
diesen krieg was ja auch eher
ungewöhnlich ist mit kritik hält man
sich in russland ja sonst eher zurück
und da heißt es sie fordern putin auf
das töten der russe der ukrainischen
brüder und schwestern in der ukraine
sofort zu beenden dankeschön nach moskau
christian semler dass der strom der
flüchtlinge aus der ukraine heraus der
reißt nicht ab im gegenteil über eine
halbe million menschen haben es
inzwischen in richtung westen geschafft
die meisten brachten sich über die
polnische grenze in sicherheit ein
kraftakt wäre derzeit etwa am
grenzübergang medica ausreisen will muss
auf ukrainischer seite mehr als drei
tage in der kälte warten natalie steger
berichtet ohne männer ohne väter werden
sie die ukraine verlassen wie der
bedrückende szenen auf der ukrainischen
seite am grenzübergang zum polnischen
musiker männer zwischen 18 und 60 jahren
dürfen das land nicht verlassen sie
sollen kämpfen
nur die kinder und meine frau gehen
ich kehre nach lewis zurück in den krieg
endlich in polen wer es geschafft hat
ist oft tage unterwegs wie diana und die
kinder
am ersten tag der bombardierung flug
eine rakete über das gebäude wir wohnen
im vierzehnten stopp wir hatten angst zu
bleiben weil die nächste rakete unser
haus hätte treffen können
noch kommen züge an aus kiew und lwiw
etwa am polnischen grenzbahnhof in
chemischen wer verwandte hat kommt
schnell weiter andere wissen nicht wohin
viele polen wollen helfen wie der nutzer
und yesss
wir haben zimmer ein eigenes haus wir
suchen nach einer mutter mit kindern die
wir aufnehmen können
wer mit dem zug weiter will in polen
muss nicht bezahlen auch viele ausländer
sind aus der ukraine geflohen tausende
junge leute studieren dort ich komme aus
der ukraine aus einer schwierigen
situation gott sei dank sind wir hier
und dank der polin die uns aufgenommen
haben es war schwierig in der ukraine
sehr
zwischenstation polnisches grenzgebiet
zwischen erleichterung und verzweiflung
weil die rückkehr in die heimat in
weiter ferne scheint
ja viele menschen in der ukraine
brauchen jetzt dringend hilfe spenden
können sie über das aktionsbündnis
katastrophenhilfe
es leistet humanitäre hilfe unter
anderem mit notunterkünften bietet
lebensmittel für binnenflüchtlinge die
ihr zuhause verloren haben das stichwort
zdf note für ukraine bahn.de 65 104 106
100 104 106 100 weitere infos auf
spenden zdf.de beziehungsweise auf der
zdf textseite 890 ja eine krisensitzung
jagt derzeit die nächste heute in
brüssel die eu verteidigungsminister
es ging um den kauf und die lieferung
von waffen für die ukraine im großen
stil im wert von einer halben milliarde
euro ja die abkehr von festen
standpunkten ist also in brüssel also
auch zu sehen und wir wollen das mit
anne gellinek besprechen grünes licht
für die eu waffenlieferungen an die
ukraine wies das einzuschätzen
ja auch hier in der europäischen union
gibt es in diesen tagen viele erste male
der eu außenbeauftragten sprach heute
von einem tabubruch der darin besteht
dass zum ersten mal in der geschichte
der europäischen geld ausgegeben wird
von der europäischen union für
waffenlieferungen
die eu außenminister hatten gestern
abend beschlossen dass sie aus einem
fonds der eigentlich für stabilisierende
friedensmissionen gedacht ist eine halbe
milliarde euro herausnehmen für
waffenkäufe für die ukraine und als die
rede von tödlichen waffen von
panzerbrechenden und großkalibrigen
waffen und ich als europa
korrespondentin musste mich heute schon
ein bisschen kneifen als der die top
diplomat vor unseren kameras
waffengattungen aufzählte die er gerne
und einstimmig von allen
mitgliedsstaaten beschlossen in die
ukraine liefern will die eu will jetzt
eine art schnittstelle sein zwischen den
mitgliedstaaten die die waffen kaufen
oder bereitstellen und der ukraine die
sagt was sie braucht in polen soll eine
art zwischenlager eingerichtet werden
von dort sollen die waffen dann in die
ukraine gelangen also man kann heute
abend sagen das friedensprojekt euro
tritt auch in eine neue phase ein dann
danke für die hintergründe anne gellinek
die technischen störung bitten wir zu
entschuldigen
als antwort auf den einmarschbefehl
putins hat der westen ja ein
umfangreiches sanktionspaket geschnürt
die meisten russischen banken wurden vom
internationalen zahlungssystemen swift
abgetrennt damit sind auch geschäfte mit
russischen firmen fast unmöglich der
flugverkehr von europa nach russland und
zurück ist praktisch eingestellt und der
transfer moderner technologien etwa bei
der rohstoffförderung ist untersagt das
alles hat harte konsequenzen auch für
die deutsche wirtschaft ralf zimmermann
von siewert weit über 1000
mitgliedsfirmen der hamburger
handelskammer sind im ukraine aber auch
im russland geschäft aktiv eine
task-force beschäftigt sich hier mit den
größten aktuellen song hin der
unternehmen für beide länder viel
unsicherheit viele
rechtliche fragen die sich stellen was
darf man noch einen ganzen verkehr aber
auch eine große sorge natürlich wenn ich
standort in der ukraine habe was
passiert mit den mitarbeitenden hier im
südukrainischen odessa beispielsweise
betreibt hamburg ein eigenes container
terminal mit 450 beschäftigten schon
seit donnerstag ruht hier die arbeit
aber auch die weltweiten logistikketten
über hamburg und ebenso über rotterdam
und antwerpen nach russland sind mit
großen fragezeichen versehen
russland hat ja im quasi keine großen
häfen wo große schiffe an landen können
sondern alles was russland importiert
und exportiert muss über andere hilfen
verladen werden die westlichen
sanktionsmaßnahmen gegen russische
banken für viele bedeuten sie harte
konsequenzen wobei manche unternehmen
bei aller unsicherheit zunächst kaum
betroffen sind aktuell haben wir keine
auswirkungen durch die schrift
sanktionen weil wir mit den betroffenen
russischen banken kein geschäftsverkehr
pflegen es wird allerdings durch die
aussetzung dieses systems sicherlich
sehr viel schwieriger die kommunikation
über die stadt die zahlungsströme in
zukunft darauf ich zu erhalten auch für
infrastrukturprojekte in russland
stellen sich dramatische fragen wie etwa
für diesen hafen neubau eines
hamburgischen projektierers an
deutschlands außen- handels- drehkreuz
ist wie der ganzen republik nur eines
zur zeit sicher die unsicheren
wirtschaftlichen aussichten
es gibt ökonomischer turbulenzen und
politische nicht nur ein drastischer
kurswechsel in der sicherheitspolitik
auch die energiepolitik muss noch mal
ganz neu nachdenken wie sie die großen
lieferausfälle von russischen gas öl und
kohle ausgleichen will kurz mittel und
langfristig mehr von heike slansky
der energiehunger der deutschen gestillt
maßgeblich von einem aggressor nun
greifen die härtesten
wirtschaftssanktionen gegen russland mit
ausnahmen die energieimporte zum
beispiel wurden ausgeklammert über die
sanktionen die man trifft braucht eine
gewisse durchhaltefähigkeit es bringt
nichts eine sensation zu erlassen die
man nach wenigen wochen wieder kassieren
muss weil man es selber nicht
durchhalten deutschlands abhängigkeit
von russischen energie importen 50
prozent des gases 35 prozent des rohöls
und 50 prozent der kohle kommen aus
russland was ist wenn putin den hahn
abdreht wenn russland gar keine energie
mehr liefert können wir kurzfristig auf
andere länder auch ausweichen das geht
beim gas beim öl und kohle ist das
weniger problematisch aber es hat zur
folge dass die preise für fossile
energie sehr stark nach oben gehen
bereits jetzt treiben energiekosten die
inflation in die höhe mehr wind und
solar die losung die energiewende soll
noch schneller vorankommen kurzfristig
setzt die regierung
auf teureres flüssiggas die
verbraucherpreise müssen dann
kompensiert werden durch
sozialpolitische maßnahmen oder
gegebenenfalls durch finanzpolitische
maßnahmen indem man weitere bestandteile
des preises zurück nimmt alles steht auf
dem prüfstand längere laufzeiten von
kohlekraftwerken der ausstieg vom
ausstieg aus der atomkraft letzteres
sieht die umweltministerin kritisch es
wird unsere sicherheit nicht erhöhen die
betreiber sagen selber dass dies nicht
möglich ist sondern weitere
unsicherheitsfaktoren dazu kommen
könnten deutschland ändert die
einkaufsstrategie und plant den aufbau
einer nationalen gasreserve ziel vor dem
nächsten winter über dann volle
gasspeicher zu verfügen
wegen des russischen überfalls auf die
ukraine ist in new york die uno
vollversammlung zu einer
dringlichkeitssitzung zusammengekommen
der ersten seit rund 40 jahren die
sitzung begann mit einer schweigeminute
am ende der zweitägigen debatte soll
über eine resolution abgestimmt werden
die den russischen angriff verurteilt
und zu einem ende der kämpfe in der
ukraine aufruft
es gibt eine beeindruckend große
solidaritätswelle für die ukraine
gestern in berlin heute in köln dazu
später mehr in unserer sendung
unterstützung drückt sich aber nicht nur
in demonstrationszügen aus sondern wir
uns jetzt melanie haack zeigt auch in
form von hilfslieferungen wie sie in
thüringen organisiert werden
unzählige kisten kommen seit tagen
medikamente schmerzmittel verbände erste
hilfe für die krankenhäuser in der
ukraine
organisiert vom thüringer verein
ukrainischer landsleute
was mit einem aufruf anfing entwickelte
sich zu einer thüringenweiten hilfswelle
die auch alexander übermannt er sortiert
mittut wasser von erfurt aus tun kann
von unternehmen krankenhäusern apotheken
kommen die spenden die daniel fuhrmann
koordiniert ich hatte eine stunde lang
das handy auch flugmodus mal es sind
über 90 anrufe reingekommen und jeder
anruf ist eine spende karin und susanne
haben mit den nachbarn gesammelt
haben wir müssen irgendwas machen da
kann man glaube ich ich glaube das lässt
keinen kalt oder am wochenende sind die
ersten transporte an die polnisch
ukrainischen grenze gefahren von dort
wurden die spenden weiter verladen von
dort haben sie verwandte aus der west
ukraine auf der flucht mitgenommen
angekommen heute morgen um drei in
apolda
wir haben ein kleinkind dabei und waren
einen ganzen tag unterwegs
im auto gefahren und hoffte nur dass
meine freunde sind ins ausland
geflüchtet ich habe gehört wie es
überall kleid dann sind wir ins dorf und
sie sind erst mal in sicherheit kevins
vater und opa mussten bleiben und zu
kämpfen
da muss man erstmal durchatmen zum krieg
in der ukraine auch heute wieder ein zdf
spezial gleich hier im anschluss und zu
jeder zeit auf dem letzten stand der
ereignisse und entwicklung sind sie mit
unserem live blog in der zdf- heute- app
dass der krieg in der ukraine im fokus
der welt öffentlichkeit steht heißt
natürlich nicht dass andere globale
krisen aufhören zu existieren zum
beispiel die gefahren durch den
klimawandel noch sei das schlimmste
abzuwenden sagt der weltklimarat heute
aber das zeitfenster zu handeln werde
kleiner schon jetzt seien bis 3,6
milliarden menschen durch die folgen des
klimawandels stark gefährdet baku
nach wochenlanger hitze jetzt
sintflutartige regenfälle mindestens
acht menschen sterben im osten
australiens in den fluten zehntausende
häuser sind beschädigt oder zerstört
solche extreme nehmen zu gefährden oft
auch ganze ökosysteme doch gerade die
sind wichtig im kampf gegen die
erderwärmung das mensch artenvielfalt
und klima eng verknüpft sind macht der
weltklimarat deutlich wie nie auch im
prinzip ein einen kurswechsel hin zu
schutz von natur und ihrer restaurierung
um letztendlich global gesehen etwa 30
bis 50 prozent der fläche an land und in
den ozeanen aus der intensiven nutzung
zu nehmen der natur bindet co2 und
liefert den menschen nahrung und wasser
die kernergebnisse des berichts
klimafolgen nehmen zu sind bereits
größer als vorhergesagt bis zu 3,6
milliarden menschen stuft der bericht
als hochgradig gefährdet ein auch die
artenvielfalt gerät unter druck und die
anpassungsmaßnahmen reichen bisher nicht
aus gerade in den wachsenden städten in
denen schon rund die hälfte der
weltbevölkerung lebt hitze oder
starkregen müssen hier mitgedacht werden
was zusätzliche wachstum verstecken muss
so gestehen das würde dass wir möglichst
wenig vielleicht versiegeln dass
möglichst viele kalten eisen offen
halten das mit viel wasser und auch im
fläche für wasserabfluss zurückbringen
in die städte effiziente klima
anpassungen sind dabei dringend mahnt
der klimarat denn die erderwärmung und
ihre folgen lassen dafür nur noch wenig
zeit
noch das zum thema corona seit heute für
impfen weitere bundesländer den proteine
im stoff nowak zum beispiel berlin
thüringen und rheinland pfalz die zahl
der neuinfektionen sinkt weiter das
robert koch institut meldet aktuell 62
1349 betroffene binnen 24 stunden
11.500 18 weniger als vor einer woche 24
todesfälle kamen hinzu die sieben tage
incidents liegt jetzt bei 1.200
38,2
nach der eindrucksvollen
solidaritätsbekundung mit der ukraine
gestern in berlin zog köln heute nach
der traditionellen rosenmontagsumzug
viel aus stattdessen ein friedensmarsch
in der karnevalshochburg
250.000 menschen waren dabei sagt die
polizei ralph goldmann berichtet schon
am vormittag hatten sich zehntausende am
chlodwigplatz versammelt im laufe des
tages wurden es immer mehr friedensdemo
statt rosen wer wollte konnte im kostüm
gegen den krieg und gegen putin
protestieren
ich finde das eine tolle mischung dass
man sowas zusammenbringen kann dass man
trotz der des kalibers gefüllt trotzdem
dieses gemeinschaftsgefühl auch hier
zeigen kann das passt super zusammen es
ist aber schön zu sehen dass es einfach
sehr viele leute sind die super ernst
nehmen und die auch einfach sehr
betroffen und sehr ernst mit dabei sind
in düsseldorf findet der rosenmontagszug
wegen krone erst ende mai statt
wagenbauer jacques tilly hat sich
trotzdem etwas einfallen lassen wladimir
putin der sich an dem großen haken
ukraine verschluckt hat die kommentieren
wir das und wünschen ihnen erstickt dran
um zu zeigen halt hoffentlich wird das
ihm für ihn politisch katastrophal enden
in köln wird putin als trotziges kind
dargestellt dass sich die gute alte zeit
zurück wünscht die karnevalisten wollen
damit ein klares zeichen setzen
das ist uns schon was ganz großartig ist
diese unterstützung zu spüren wir hoffen
dass die signale weit über köln raus
tragen dass man das in der ukraine und
in russland auch wahrnimmt was wir hier
heute macht an diesem rosenmontag
dominierenden köln die farben blau und
gelb und eine klare botschaft freiheit
für die ukraine
wir sind beim sport und kommen auch an
russland ukraine krieg hier nicht vorbei
katja ja es ist das beherrschende thema
die großen international internationalen
verbände wie die uefa die fifa und auch
das internationale olympische komitee
haben reagiert und russland von
sämtlichen internationalen
sportveranstaltungen ausgeschlossen
bisher schienen sich thomas bach und la
die mir putin überwiegend wohl gesonnen
das verhältnis ist nun ernsthaft getrübt
das internationale olympische komitee
empfiehlt jetzt auf seiner website keine
athleten und offizielle aus russland und
belarus zum internationalen wettkämpfen
zuzulassen im minutentakt sid der
fußball weltverband nach die fifa
suspendiert russland von all ihren
wettbewerben präsident infantino es
offenkundige sympathien für
autokratische staaten spielen oft mag
keine rolle mehr auch die uefa hatte
zuvor russland die rote karte gezeigt
russische mannschaften werden auch unter
dem dach des europäischen
fussballverbandes bis auf weiteres keine
spiele bestreiten
zum nächsten großereignis den winter
paralympics sind russische aktive noch
zugelassen ob sie am freitag zur
eröffnungsfeier unter neutraler flagge
wie 2018 einmarschieren scheint
allerdings immer fraglicher derweil ist
schalke 04 aus seinem bis 2025 gültigen
sponsorenvertrag mit dem russischen
konzern gazprom ausgestiegen der
vereinsname auf den trikots soll
möglichst bald gegen einen
unbedenklichen nachfolger ausgetauscht
werden
und wie vor wenigen minuten bekannt
wurde hat auch die uefa die
zusammenarbeit mit dem russischen
hauptsponsor gazprom mit sofortiger
wirkung beendet in der fußball
bundesliga kann der bvb die klitzekleine
hoffnung den bayern den titel eventuell
doch noch streitig zu machen so langsam
abhaken gestern spielten die dortmunder
nur 1 1 gegen augsburg zwar begannen die
dortmunder stark und apps bewusst hier
der führungstreffer von nasa in der 35
minute doch der bvb konnte die führung
nicht über die zeit retten sarin
rennbahn see mit dem 1 1 in der 78
minute dortmund in der tabelle jetzt
acht punkte hinter den führenden bayern
das war's für ein dankeschön katja es
bleibt richtig schön sonnig mehr gleich
von ostend ali um 21.45 das heute
journal mit marietta slomka und gleich
direkt weiter mit einem zdf spezial zur
lage in der ukraine
danke und guten abend
[Musik]
und herzlich willkommen zum wetter der
hohen luftdruck wird etwas gestört und
zwar über den norden zieht eine
kaltfront aber da fällt kaum etwas raus
nur wolken sind unterwegs sonst haben
wir es mit viel sonnenschein morgen im
tagesverlauf zu tun in der nacht klart
es bereits verbreitet auf nur nach
nordosten sind die wolken mal dichter
die temperaturen gehen zurück bis auf
minus elf grad hier also strenger frost
sonst teils mäßiger oder leichter frost
frostfrei ganz im westen deutschlands
morgen dann zum beginn des
meteorologischen frühlings im osten
sonnenschein und auch im süden sonne
ganz im norden der kaltfront geschuldet
hier dichtere wolken die temperaturen
erreichen werte 4 grad richtung osten 5
grad an den alpen und 10 grad am
niederrhein die kommenden tage gehen
soll ich weiter und einige dichtere
wolken im osten deutschlands bei 5 bis
13 grad am mittwoch und donnerstag und
freitag weiterhin sonnenschein bei
ähnlichen temperaturen und damit wünsche
ich ihnen ein schöner abend